(audience applauding)
- All right, well, welcome, everyone.
We're really sorry Gina
Raimondo couldn't make it today,
but my sincere hope is
that she will manage
to keep all of us doing our
necessary work here (chuckles)
with her duties in Washington.
(audience chuckling)
So good afternoon.
I'm Jeff Brock.
I'm the Dean of the School of Engineering
and Applied Science,
and it gives me great pleasure
to bring today the second of our series
in the "Dean's Invited Speaker Series."
These are a new series
that we've inaugurated
to try to bring members of our community,
the larger Yale community, who
are highly placed in industry
into conversation with all of you
and with the larger Yale community.
So many of our alums have made their way
to the top of the industrial
world in one role or another.
They have incredible stories.
And our guest today
really implementizes that
probably more than any of our alums.
So I'm really pleased to welcome C.C. Wei,
who joins us in part, in
addition to this grand event,
to receive the Wilbur
Cross Medal this evening
from the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences.
Let's give a round of applause for that.
(audience applauding)
So just a couple of words
about C.C.'s trajectory,
he received his graduate degree,
his PhD, here in the 1980s,
just before I arrived on campus.
We just missed each other. (chuckles)
And he then went on to a
role as a research scientist
and working at Texas Instruments,
semiconductor corporation.
Ultimately, found his way
to leading Taiwan Semiconductor
Manufacturing Company,
or TSMC, which has been in the news,
and which you no doubt have
heard of if you're here.
So I won't go through all of the twists
and turns of his career and the
other academic institutions,
which may deserve some measure of credit
for his arriving at this
sort of pinnacle in industry.
But really, my goal is to
have just an easy conversation
with Dr. Wei here
and to hear about some
recent collaboration
that he has been involved
in with the United States
and how that reflects his worldview.
And so we'll just engage
in about 25 minutes
or so of conversation,
and then I'm eager to open it
up to this wonderful crowd.
And thank you, again, all for coming.
Now let me welcome C.C. Wei.
(audience applauding)
- [C.C.] Thank you, Jeff.
- Okay.
Now maybe you'll turn down
the volume for a minute,
so we can open our Diet Cokes.
Exactly. (chuckles)
All right, so I have the honor
and privilege of opening it up here today,
but I guess I'm just curious
how you came to Yale,
how you saw Yale as a
direction you wanted to pursue,
and what you think it gave you
in terms of your trajectory forward.
- That's a good question.
- You are wearing a Yale tie,
so it must have meant
something to you. (laughs)
- Well, starting with this tie,
(audience laughing)
this is a only chance I
can wear a tie with proud.
I mean, that's a...
(audience laughing)
If I wear this one in my company,
a lot of people will protest.
(audience laughing)
Because they graduate
from the different school.
They think they are the best.
(audience laughing)
Anyway, here is the best.
(audience applauding)
Look, why I join Yale?
It's interesting.
This is because of it's a name brand.
You know that what is called a name brand?
The Harvard, Yale, and Stanford, MIT,
those are the name brand.
So when I receive...
I apply many schools when I
want to have a graduate study.
And one day, I received the admission,
and I still waiting for other
school to give me the reply,
but then my family, my brother especially,
he say, "Hey, young brother, this is Yale.
Is that the same as in the newspaper?
Is a Harvard, Yale?"
I say, "Yes."
He say, "Then what are you waiting for?
Just go over there."
(audience laughing)
I mean, I say, "Well, I'm still
waiting for Carnegie Mellon
or those kind of a school."
He say, "What the melon?
Melon is a fruit.
(audience laughing)
Don't go over there."
So, well, I accepted Yale.
But joke aside, actually, Professor Ma
is one of the reason that
I decide to join Yale.
And because of I have my
school professor, Dr. C.Y. Wu,
he's a classmate of Professor Ma,
and I think that Professor
Wu is a nice professor,
then Professor Ma must be as good as him.
In fact, he's better.
He's the best.
(audience laughing)
And I learned a lot from Professor Ma.
And today, Professor Ma's wife is here
and I'm grateful to them.
Pin-Fang, yes.
(audience applauding)
And then to tell you truth,
when I was studying Yale,
it's a endless work, a lot of pressure,
and a long working hour.
So I thought, I say,
"This is hell of my life.
I need to get out as quickly as possible."
(audience laughing)
And I tried, but I failed, of course.
You still have to stay five
years and something like that.
And in between, I talked
to Professor Barker,
we are in the same group.
I say, "Professor Barker,
how can I get out quickly?"
Then he look at me, he say, "You don't.
You don't get out.
Have you ever enjoy Yale?"
I say, "How to enjoy Yale?"
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
In my life, it's the Helen Hadley Hall,
the tunnel to Becton Center,
the library in Becton Center,
and never-ending.
So he look at me, he say,
"Have you ever listened
to any speech in the law school?"
I say, "What the hell?
Why I need to...
(audience laughing)
I want to graduate.
That's all, right?"
I mean, that's a...
So he did not give me the right answer.
So I be patient.
But finally, finally, what I got from Yale
is I got a PhD degree,
but I also very proud
to meet one young lady
that I fell in love with, and
then finally become my wife.
My wife is here, Jessica.
(audience applauding)
And then with her, I have
three lovely kids, okay?
One of them is with me, Terry.
(audience applauding)
Okay, I tell the truth.
I got what I want.
I have a degree, I have my wife,
and then the life goes on, right?
And I thought that would
be a rosy picture ahead.
But actually, it's not.
If you work on the semiconductor industry,
you have to work hard.
It's by nature because
of this semiconductor
is a very important industry.
Finally, we knew that.
But 40 years ago, it's not.
40 years ago, EE is not so,
let me say that, is not so popular.
Now today, is more important.
Okay, I got all my story in here.
(Jeff chuckles)
(audience laughing)
- So I was telling C.C. earlier
that semiconductors are hot.
Look at the presence here today.
So what would you say
about kind of the American
culture resonates with you
in terms of developing
creativity, productivity?
Why might you be inclined to
work with the US government
to develop this partnership?
- That's a good question.
Actually, there's a lot of rumor says
that TSMC had been
pressured by US government
to come to US to build a fab.
To tell the truth, it's
not really that story.
In Taiwan, we start to
see the limitation of...
The number one limitation
that in Taiwan I have
is talented people.
The limitation of amount of talent people.
And to tell the truth, US is a country
that with the most innovative,
talented people here,
like you guy are, okay?
Very innovative, very kind
of wild dream-driven people.
And especially for the Ivy League student,
they're always being
trained to be the leader.
So you guys don't think something small.
You will be the leader in your industry,
in your career one day.
And so now talk about why TSMC want
to build a fab in the US.
Simple, because of US
where have a huge amount
of talent people that I can look for,
and we can have some
select of the talent people
to join TSMC in US.
At the same time, the US also
think about the government,
also think about semiconductor
is very important.
It indeed is very important
because this semiconductor
is a center of every technology.
You name it.
In the future, you name it.
You want to have more
advance in medical care?
You need a semiconductor.
You want to have autonomous driving?
You want to have a AI
application in every industry?
You need semiconductor.
So US government suddenly realize that.
I say suddenly because
they never talk with TSMC.
Now, they talk very often.
(audience laughing)
So actually, I expect
to have a same occasion
that Secretary Raimondo here.
But anyway, so finally,
I mean, why we choose US?
It's not we choose US.
This is a natural choice
because you need the talent
of people here, okay?
And by the way, US
government also promised
to help TSMC to build the fab in Arizona.
So we choose it, we like it,
and we have some problem.
No doubt, you just read the newspaper.
But then we will overcome
all those kind of thing.
We took it as a kind of a learning cycle.
And then we're going to
build more fab in the US.
And welcome you guys to join, by the way.
(Jeff chuckles)
(audience laughing)
- So you mentioned the
characteristics of the undergraduates
and graduate students that we
train in terms of leadership.
What would you see as challenges
that universities face now
in terms of technical training?
What kinds of techniques
should we be emphasizing
in terms of curriculum?
- Technical?
That's interesting.
I never touched that area
for more than 10 years.
(audience laughing)
Nowadays, I use my lip service.
- Same here, by the way.
(all laughing)
- That's why we sit here.
- Yeah. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
- Actually, my wife joke with me,
say that if I cannot speak it out,
I can ask my kids to help
me to deliver the speech.
In undergraduate...
Let me use one joke.
One time I talked with Professor Barker.
So Professor Barker say
that, as a professor,
he has to treat the
undergraduate student very well
because most of them will be
the leader in the industry,
for the good student, when
you have a good track record.
When the student have a good track record,
they will become professor,
so they will become his colleagues.
So deal with them politely.
(audience laughing)
When the student with a
bad record, the bad score,
they will be the industry leader.
(audience laughing)
They will donate money to the school.
So be nice to them, also.
(audience laughing)
For those graduate student, ignore them
because of they are useless sometimes.
(audience laughing)
Okay, now joke aside,
I would think the best Ivy
League, so the school, actually,
to train the future leader,
that's very important.
I'm not very good at the
technical, to be frank with you.
I'm a mediocre student.
When Professor Ma give me
the score, it's mediocre.
(Jeff chuckles)
So I'm the one that
graduated, but this school,
Yale, this school, will
train the future leader.
You look at how many
of US president we have
from this school.
We're the best in the law school, right?
(Jeff chuckles)
Engineering, I don't know.
I mean, that's-
- We're getting,
we're getting, right?
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
But then we will be the
leaders in the industry.
Look at me.
I don't need to have a very good score,
but I still can be the leader, yeah.
(audience laughing)
Don't worry, you will get it.
By the way, the trick is
that you had to live longer.
- Right, yeah.
(audience laughing)
So stay healthy.
Okay, so you've teed up my next question,
which is, at what point
when you were working
through your career did
you see opportunities
for leadership?
What made you choose to
head in that direction
as opposed to research and engineering?
- Well, the answer is very simple.
I'm not good at research.
(audience laughing)
So by nature, you have to
choose another route, right?
To be frank with you, in my
career, we had to be humble.
We had to be humble
during my whole career.
So I know a lot of talented people.
They can do much better work
than me in terms of technical.
But I'm not too bad
either, by the way, okay?
I have a few papers and
about 30 to 40 patent,
30 to 40 papers and speeches.
But then I'm not the very best of it.
However, during your career,
you continue to be humble, humility,
and you had to be,
love what you have doing with your work.
That's a trick. That's a trick.
You've got to be happy.
Only when you are happy,
you can work hard.
But how to become happy,
well, how you are going to love your work,
you have to find the
pleasure inside your work.
That's a trick.
If you cannot find the
pleasure, don't do it.
Change to another company
or change your boss.
I don't know, ah, usually.
(audience laughing)
But in reality, you cannot
change your boss, right?
So you try to find some
pleasure with your work,
and then you are become
happy, and then you work hard.
I always believe that everybody's
a wisdom almost equal.
You are not much smarter
than other people,
but working hard, enjoy it,
and then you can work all the way through.
And by nature, you are become
the leader of your group
and then become the
leader of a bigger group
and become the leader of a
company, like me right now.
To be frank with you, I
am lucky all the time,
(audience chuckling)
whether you believe you or not.
- Mm-hmm.
(chuckles) So your advisor, T.P. Ma,
was one of these larger-than-life
sort of warm personas,
and we miss him dearly.
Probably there were nevertheless
moments when you had doubts
about your chosen direction,
as we all do as graduate students.
What were the things that kept you going?
What can you offer this
group in terms of motivation
for the hard moments?
- Yeah, so what motivation?
'Cause when I was a graduate student,
the life is tough, right?
I mean, I have to work for a long hour
all the way to the night.
So the motivation is to
get out of this school
as quickly as possible.
(audience laughing)
And then I will have a better life, right?
- [Jeff] Yeah, yeah.
- The same motivation that
when I was working in TI.
I'm an engineer, so I
say, "What I am doing?
I still work day and night."
So I want to be promoted to manager
so I will have a better life.
(Jeff chuckles)
(audience chuckling)
So once I get the managerial job,
I say, "Oh, boy, I got to be
a VP, so then I can relax."
(audience chuckling)
So I was a VP in TSMC.
Then I found out,
God, boy, I work for a very
top boss, Dr. Morris Chang.
So I say, "Oh, boy, I mean, that's a...
I got to be a CEO to get rid
of this nightmare."
(audience laughing)
And then I start to regret
that the nightmare never disappear.
(audience laughing)
So motivation?
Motivation is usually you
think the future is better, but
(audience laughing)
it's not really.
So just give you a good
advice, okay, guys?
You realize that in your
life you always have a dream
and the dream come true, but
not the same dream as you have.
(Jeff chuckles)
- All right, well, I
think that's what I wanted
to ask our friend, but I'm
sure you have many questions
you might want to pose to C.C.
I don't know if there are any hands?
Anyone wanna raise a question?
Yeah, over here.
Thank you, Elizabeth.
- The vast majority of US military planes
have Taiwanese chips in them.
And the semiconductors
were made in your company.
And I'm just wondering where
you think the supply lines
for these chips will
evolve in the coming years?
Thank you.
- You can either
(audience laughing)
(laughs) agree or decline
to answer this.
(C.C. laughs)
- That's a interesting question
that I don't have a perfect answer.
I mean, that you are talking about
like the US government official talking
to me that...
(audience laughing)
This is related to the national security
or related to the resilience
of the supply to the US.
To be frank with you, in my point of view,
the semiconductor industry is globalized.
Every country doing
what he can do the best.
But among them, the biggest,
let me say not the biggest,
the strongest country in
semiconductor industry is the USA.
Okay.
You guys don't get
misled by the newspaper,
by all the rumors say
that, "Oh, manufacturing?
Taiwan is very good," and blah blah blah.
(Jeff chuckles)
The strongest country in
semiconductor industry is USA.
Now the US is kind of
putting manufacturing aside
for a while,
but if US decide to pick
it up quickly, they will.
And why I say the strongest country
in semiconductor industry is
because of all the process,
all the technology development.
You need the very advanced tools.
And all the advanced tool originated,
all being manufactured in the US.
That's why it become the strongest.
I using the photolithography
as one of the example.
Today, the most advanced
photolithography tool is a UV.
Is anybody know what's called UV?
That's all?
And all other people didn't know?
Okay, now, let's say anybody
who did not understand UV stands
for, except my wife, okay.
(audience laughing)
Okay, good.
I mean, that's kind of a
very small wavelength tools.
And the central part
of the UV is in the US,
the light source.
The light source to generate such kind
of a very short
wavelengths is from the US.
No doubt about it.
And using TSMC as an example,
I use a lot of Applied
Materials as a tools.
I use a lot of Lam Research
as a tool, and KLA-Tencor,
and a lot of software from Mentor Graphic,
or now it become Siemens, or...
Okay, I forgot their name.
I'm sorry for that.
But Cadence,
(Jeff chuckles)
and then Synopsys, and those
guys, those are from US.
Without them, you cannot develop
or you cannot design any product.
So part of the reason I
can answer Jeff's question,
"Why choose US as a partner?"
Of course, this is the best country
for the semiconducting industry.
What else I can choose?
So if I have a choice,
US is the number one place I will choose.
Produce enough chips
inside US takes time, okay?
So be patient.
(audience laughing)
That's the same answer I answer
that US government officials.
(audience laughing)
Be patient.
- Be patient.
Okay, there's another one over here.
- [Microphone Runner] Sorry.
- Hi, I'm Frank.
So my question is, even though US is one
of the more higher-tech
countries in the world,
what made Taiwan such a
fertile ecosystem for TSMC
to develop there versus
being in the US originally?
- Oh, you're talking about the ecosystem
for the whole manufacturing
of a semiconductor?
- Sure.
- The same answer, be patient.
(audience laughing)
It takes time to build up, right?
I mean that's a...
TSMC has been in Taiwan for 30 years.
The whole ecosystem, including
to set up a building,
to set up a fab, the construction
worker, to be specific,
and also, the facility
worker and everybody,
and also, the chemical supply,
the raw material supply,
it takes Taiwan for more
than 30 years to be mature.
And so I would expect...
I don't think the US need 30 years.
US can catch up quickly
because of this is the
best place in the world
that you have a lot of talented people.
And all the key is talented people.
And so when US decide to focus
on the semiconductor manufacturing,
it will be catching up
quickly, but it takes time.
It takes time.
Not 30 years, of course.
Much shorter than that.
- (chuckles) All right, next question?
- [Audience Member 1] First, I
wanna say thank you very much
for coming.
It's really a privilege to
be able to listen to you.
I also ask, so since
you made the transition
from being a engineer to a
manager, how did you know...
Do you have any advice for being able
to make that transition
from managing circuits
to managing people?
And do you have any
advice in regard to that?
- Tell the truth, managing
people is very tough.
You might want to read a book
that's being written by President Salovey.
He's a guy invented the EQ
and how to manage the people.
Please read his book.
(audience chuckling)
I regret a lot that I
did not read his book
and being promoted to a manager's job.
I like to manage the machine
because they don't protest.
(audience laughing)
Managing the people are very
tough because of, for example,
if they are not, have a
quarrel with his wife,
then his temper become very bad.
How did I know?
I mean that yesterday,
he's my nice, good friend,
and today, he show his face on me.
So I don't understand that,
so I give him a hard time just so...
Usually, you change from a technical role
to become managerial's role,
you had to pay more attention
to people's daily life,
which is very dynamic, and
so it's a very tough job.
And so if you are very good
manager, I always ask my guy,
"If you want to be
promoted to be a manager,
you got to get married.
(audience laughing)
You know how to manage your family,
then you are become a good manager."
(audience chuckling)
No joke.
I tell them that, "If you are not married,
I will not promote you to the manager."
(audience laughing)
(Jeff chuckles)
- Over here.
- [Audience Member 2] If and
how do you see TSMC essential
in countering Chinese rising
global technological influence
and semiconductor industry?
- The question is, from my point of view,
to look at how China?
- [Audience Member 2] Yeah,
countering China's semiconductor industry
and your global technological influence.
(Jeff chuckles)
- I don't make a public
comment on China, by the way.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
To be frank with you guys,
I was not allowed to give a speech
without go through my legal department.
So I prepare no (indistinct)
because they say that,
"C.C., you probably have a big mouth.
So we don't,
(audience laughing)
we don't allow you to
talk about something,
one, two, three, four, five, six, seven."
And finally, I decide, say,
"I have to keep silent."
(audience laughing)
So I don't make a comment on my customer.
I don't make a comment on US, China,
as a political confrontation.
I don't make a comment on China.
I have a lot of customer
in China, by the way.
They all use TSMC.
And besides, the one being
put on the Entity List
was my second-largest
customer, and I lost that.
But anyway, no, thank you.
No comment.
(audience laughing and clapping)
- Okay, another one over here.
- [Audience Member 3] Hi, so I'm sure,
throughout your career,
you've had a lot of mentors and sponsors.
I'm curious to hear who some of them were
and why you picked them out.
- I did not catch question.
- Who some of your mentors were
and why you sought them out.
- So I pretend I don't
understand her question.
(Jeff laughs)
For the mental work?
- [Audience Member 3] Oh, mentors.
- Mentors.
- Yeah, do you-
- Yeah, like T.P.
- Always from the T.P. Ma,
starting from T.P. Ma first, right?
I learned a lot from
all my mentors per se.
I have four person in my life.
The first one, T.P. Ma, I learned a lot
because of T.P. is smart
and never be harsh on me,
even my academic work is mediocre.
But of course,
(Jeff laughs)
in the later days, when I
being in the VP, or senior VP,
or the CEO of TSMC, T.P. Ma
start to change his record on me
(audience chuckling)
and become better.
(audience laughing)
But actually, I learned
from T.P., he's very patient
and very kind of instructive.
And he also show me how to
write a good technical paper.
That teach me a lot.
And then after T.P. and Professor Barker,
after T.P. I joined TSMC, and
there's a talent boss, also.
In TI, I have my manager
is called Roger Haken.
Roger Haken, he passed away
when he was very young.
But in the IEEE IEDM has
a Best Student Paper Award
in name of Roger Haken.
So they call it Roger
Haken Best Student Award.
That tells you that how
important his achievement.
He's very smart.
Usually, do you know
that in our life before?
Okay, I tell you guys.
After you graduate and join a company,
you are start to write the weekly report.
And nice to be a CEO
because I don't need to
write a weekly report now.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so I have a long time
for more than 30 years continue
to write a weekly report.
Roger Haken is the one
that never cut-paste
on my weekly report
into his weekly report.
(audience chuckling)
Okay, he usually, he
read my weekly report.
If he did not understand,
he call me into his office,
and then he ask me to sit right beside him
and he start to use his own
word to write the weekly,
and ask me to read it and say that,
"Is this is exactly what you say?"
And he catch up the idea very quickly.
And then one day, he become
the senior fellow of TI.
His job grade is higher than
his boss, his boss' boss,
and directly report to the TI president.
So that's tell you that how smart he is.
And he also teach me a lot.
He give me a lot of, not instruction,
but just say, "Why this
one become like that?
Why you did not see it?"
Oh, my God, so I have to
go back and work hard.
Roger Haken.
But finally, I met with a very top one,
if you want to call them
mentor, Dr. Morris Chang.
He's a founder of TSMC.
And I learned from him a lot,
but he's still around, so I
don't want to make any comment.
(audience laughing)
- All right.
- [Audience Member 4] So
you've spoken about AI
and how your semiconductors
are necessary for this.
A woman in the front
spoke about weapon systems
and how semiconductors are
also necessary for that.
Do you think it's feasible
to introduce greater tracking
of where semiconductors are going,
of what they're being used for?
- Semiconductor, it's because
of US-China's confrontation,
so become the center
of that confrontation.
But to be frank with you,
without that, actually,
finally the people will
realize the semiconductor
is a central portion of all technology,
including whatever you want to name it,
including in our life, like...
I like to use in the
medical as one example.
I don't like to use in the military
or some kind of confrontation.
In the medical...
In the medical field, I want
to make a joke of my wife.
She only trust the guy
with experience, right?
So when you see a doctor,
you want to see a experienced doctor.
Am I right?
Okay.
But look at it.
To give you some idea, if a
doctor is 50 or 60 years old,
are you going to let that
guy to do the operation?
(audience chuckling)
Do you know that the
people's hand is not steady?
(audience laughing)
Do you want to do the experiment?
Just hold a laser pointer to the wall
and see how steady it is.
(audience laughing)
Okay, now here comes a question.
If you want to do the operation
with the hand is some kind of uncertainty
and then you let that doctor to cut it?
Not me.
I mean, I will trust that
is everything controlled
by the semiconductor, then
I will trust it, okay.
So in the future, I would
like to say the surgery
will be done by the machine.
The machine is controlled
by the semiconductor.
That's one thing.
And the other thing is
what is called experience.
Experience, that mean you
learn a lot of skill by years,
and you have to remember, by the way.
So I would say that if
you go to the hospital
to see you got the flu,
so you tell the doctor,
say, "I got the flu.
I have coughing, I have a runny nose,
and everything," blah, blah blah.
And so the doctor will say,
"Okay, sit right there."
Measure your temperature,
measure your heartbeat,
and then be very patient
with you for half an hour,
and then write down some medicine for you.
I don't need it.
I just using the AI to
collect all the flu example
in this area, and then the
AI will make a judgment,
say that what the age you
are, is a male or female,
and what the symptom,
what kind of temperature,
body temperature, what kind of heartbeat,
what kind of blah blah blah.
And then they also look
at, are you in New Haven,
or you are in New York, or
you are in Washington, DC?
And so the flu in that area of the people,
the symptom look like what?
And finally, get a conclusion
and write down the medicine for you.
And the accuracy will be 90 or 95%.
So you don't need a doctor.
You just type into the computer.
(Jeff chuckles)
And then 90 or 95% of accuracy,
you still have 5% to 10%, right?
Then you see a doctor.
And then doctor say, "It's
not working for this one."
And the computer ask, "So what years?"
And then you type it into,
so the computer continue to remember,
continue to educate itself.
And so finally, I don't
need a doctor to see
when I have a flu.
I don't need a doctor to
do the operation surgery.
I don't need a doctor
to give me some advice,
like I'm overweight.
(Jeff chuckles)
And the AI will tell me, it say, "Mr. Wei,
you are overweight for five kilogram.
You better to do the following."
And whether I follow it or not,
then I have to wear a smart watch.
And then the watch will
measure my heartbeat,
measure my temperature,
send it to a computer,
and computer give me a warning,
say that, "You are not listen to me,
so you have better watch out.
You only have how many years to live."
(audience laughing)
Then I will get nervous, right?
So I start to follow the instruction.
But anyway, in the future,
semiconductor will be the key in our life,
something like that.
Yeah, another one.
- Okay, maybe we have time
for one last question.
Yeah?
(Jeff and CC laughing)
- [Microphone Runner] Sorry.
- First of all, thank
you for the great talk
and inspiring us.
Of course, every process in
the semiconductor manufacturing
is very important.
But first decade people talk a lot
about miniaturizing the semiconductor
and integrate more and
more chips inside of,
more and more transistor
inside of the single chips.
But it's like seven
nanometer, five nanometers,
three nanometer, like that.
But now, we will facing the
limit of the miniaturizing,
the process.
So what is your insight or prospect,
which process will
attract people's attention
after the miniaturizing and
integrating the transistors?
- Good question.
Is there any...
Actually, your question should separate
into, is there any
limitation at all, okay?
And what we are doing to deal with it.
I give you a story.
When I graduated from
Yale, I joined TI in 19,
actually, at the beginning of 1985.
I graduated in 1985, but
I want to work quickly
because I have a family to raise.
So at the beginning of
the 1985, I work in TI.
I read a paper published by IBM.
They called it 1-micron technology.
And they say, "Not for long
that will reach the limitation
of the semiconductor device."
If you look at it, look at it,
look at the mean free
path of your electron
at the kind of different temperature,
you'll find out if a
channel length shorter
than your mean free path,
there's a lot of limitation.
There's a lot of high electron.
There's a lot of physics inside.
So they say, quickly,
.35 micron is the end
of the semiconductor technology, okay?
And since then, now today,
we are at three nanometer.
And so the people ask me the
same thing we ask ourselves
inside TSMC, "Is there any limitation?"
So what happen after three nanometer?
Do you know?
Two nanometer.
So what happened after two nanometer?
1.4. I tell you the truth.
You just time by .7 in one.
And so one of the occasion
I answer the question,
the people ask me, "What happen
after the 1.4 nanometer?"
I say, "One nanometer."
"And what happen after the one nanometer?"
"Of course, .7."
Something,
(audience chuckling)
something like that.
And they keep asking.
And finally, my answer
is, "Why should I care?
Because I retire already."
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
- All right, thank you again, C.C.
- Thank you, guys.
- A real pleasure.
Thank you for coming.
- Thank you, Jeff.
(audience applauding)
- Please welcome...
Enjoy some refreshments outside.
And let's thank C.C for a great night.
(audience continues applauding)
- One last word.
Don't forget to join TSMC
after you graduate.
(audience laughing)
- All right.
(audience applauding)
(bright music)
(paper rustling)